yeah welcome to the iron Lords podcast
episode 14 and the Lords are back at the
round table we apologize for a little
bit of late but we got a great show
lined up and of course the usual
suspects at the round table
so let's start off with my brother from
another mother but non agro gamer
himself Lord addict in the building how
you doing sir
cool cool cool and of course we've got
Illuminati confirmed our man detect man
Lord sovereign what's going on no
sovereign yes yes and the excess gamer
demand who demands premium experience
beloved Lord kings and building was good
[Laughter]
though
so the Lord is like going on but on
whatever the law has been playing I know
from now start off for myself um this is
actually real fun we actually got back
into destiny shout out the Lord's
sinister he'd been running these raid
boot camps at 9:00 a.m. it's text a bit
yeah it's before America we gotta get
you back in your routine you gotta get
you back in the shape baby oh okay okay
mhm
[Laughter]
yes I was doing that it had a little
ball
Mario Kart action so that was fun I just
started that join up but uh but I'd
watch what's been going on you what
you've been playing mm-hmm
okay okay Inbal sovereign what's what's
been going on with you as far as you can
play
yeah haha we were shut that dad look you
did you nice nice nice
hello Kate when you play
[Music]
you need this nice 360 baby smooth nice
no no don't look there I got my man
Quenya checks he's saying and I'm we
have a little technical issue right now
before we actually jump off you're
saying that um you can just hear me
which is not cool yeah it we get it we
gotta get you get you the crew in there
so she was going on hello personal
technical issue
yeah he's saying he's saying just just
hearing that you just hearing me right
now buddy
and um that is a problem so I don't want
a second yeah that's not good luck and
I'm so low round here any streets it's
not a good luck if worse comes to worse
we'll just we'll just switch up on young
the joint give me one second [ __ ] Oh
Josh you're crazy
mm-hmm yeah cause in this sense I think
- let's get it we're gonna done it yeah
where we started with that it he's like
what's that I see yeah I will be right
back yeah add these messages
you
oh all right uh I have no clue how that
happened I don't know it was weird innit
I literally hit lives and it did it
acted didn't bring anybody over except
me I think that fixed it but we probably
lost everyone for the day uh can anyone
hear us now
the Wow his deal is it is what it is yo
all right they can hear me Kanaka all
right cool cool cool that seemed quite
acidic here yeah yeah both of us right
we good the levels is good
yeah just for us too sorry about think
example that you got I can't add anyone
is it look younger
no buggin is our just chilling here
first
yeah I gotcha
go with them to technical difficulties
in these streets so there we go
alright can you guys hear me if we're
going to get the Menace fast and as
efficient as possible I will let you out
now oh I think so yeah it's called by
email crap I was unfortunate it was like
there was too high go I have never never
seen a do that yeah it was like it was
two sessions going on bugging out
because I was wondering why it looked
different
like I couldn't mute myself like the
mute was on the bottom and not the top
it didn't look at him Adam to her save
go go alright why wait for everyone else
to come in what you guys ask some
questions in the in the comment section
why ya ish a twerking question
nah bro yes this is this is Miss Nagas
not alone I yeah glad you're going in
right now yeah man we have an issue with
this
it's hard to tell how long it's gonna
take me the King back in here
I just intercepted oh yes in the moat oh
my god one week I don't do it see what
happens
I guess I'm forever stuck is this house
we may have that we have to just end it
again bro is this varus's so yes huh
so I'm in the Builder sock in the
building
hi there we go there we go let's go good
king of business yep I mean again I have
to apologize anyone watching this we
thought we didn't know we were the only
ones talking thank God for the chat chat
let us know what was good all right
let's just go ahead and uh it's start
one of our topics while we wait for Dee
to get his stuff yeah no doubt
all right we'll talk about Phil Spence
just call me that's nice yeah let's get
right into obviously on the topic of
discussion right now at least one of the
hottest topics going on right now is
there
the recent interview with um you're
challenging acquaintance the recent
interview going on with uh Phil Spencer
and um obviously there were some
comments made and I'm gonna let Louis
off take this away cuz I know you want
to jump right in on this as far as you
know I don't say games as a service but
um some also some comments also made his
reference to single play experiences and
stuff like that so Louis ah
what you got for the people in this all
right so basically um Phil had an
interview with The Guardian recently
where he kind of talked about um
basic focus he made a he made a
statement saying that he looks at moving
forward offering something like games as
a service as a viable way to sort of
move gaming forward and kind of evolved
the way in which people sell games and
the way people kind of consume games so
basically he had this two prong approach
where he was indicating that um
basically when it comes to games as a
service he's talking about games that
exist as a service kind of like a
destiny or a division or something like
that an addition to um how you kind of
sell games and how you present games and
and what Microsoft has been doing with
that in terms of like game paths and
stuff like that
so basically um to get into the comments
that and how people react to the
comments he made a comment indicating
that it almost seemed like he was
leaning towards Microsoft focusing on
sort of uh these these um these PvP sort
of experiences moving forward
multiplayer experiences as sort of
abandoning single-player uh and
essentially what happened with that was
that I think it got blown out of
proportion I think what Phil was trying
to indicate was that the markets are in
recent years have basically indicated
that that is that is where a lot of
gaming is being done and this morning
one is very popular you have 30 plus
million players on destiny that's not
something that you can ignore so what he
was indicating was that he wants to
create an environment for these for
these developers where both of those
type of games could thrive but he made
it very clear that something along the
lines of destiny and the division these
are things that have to be kind of at
the forefront right now and you have to
ensure that a they continue to thrive
and grow and that be because they're
thriving and growing so much you have to
create an environment where smaller
developers can get in on that action
because it's a very difficult thing for
small developers to kind of get in on
that sort of up and
progressive design philosophy where you
can create a game that's a persistent
world as you continue to build upon its
it's not cost-effective for a small team
to be able to do that so part of what I
was talking about was saying well okay
on our side what we've been trying to do
is build up our with things like the
like the cloud-based services and stuff
like that create systems within the Xbox
are a development environment that make
it easier for all developers
specifically small developers to be able
to put out a game that that's a living
game and that they can expand upon a NIC
and they can that can evolve over time
and the developer not have to worry
about having to purchase and maintain
servers and things like that so this is
what they're trying to provide in order
for these sorts of games to continue to
thrive on consoles and then he mentioned
that also in terms of single player
games where he was like well you know
what single player gaming at this point
is getting a lot more difficult to
invest millions and millions of dollars
into these single sort of bespoke
experiences that you experience for you
know 2030 hours if that and then it's
over and that's it
this is too much money involved for that
to be the end of it even if we you
consider like DLC that gets released
months down the line like story based
DLC it's still not cost-effective
so what Phil said when he was talking
about the Netflix of gaming he said
we've been talking about maybe including
in-game past something that would allow
developers to have episodic
single-player content where they're not
forced to release an entire game in one
shot they release an episode of a game
it's on the service already that you're
paying for so you're not paying extra
for it you play whatever the first
whatever five six hours of that episode
is and if it does well obviously the
revenue from that obviously the revenue
that they're already getting from the
whatever you know $10 a month game
passes or whatever is going to be and
that continues to feed into the
development the further development of
that game and what it
what it does is create an environment
where these type of games could thrive
and they don't did you not you're not
obligated to spend a hundred million
dollars on a triple-a single player game
it's going to last 20 to 30 hours and
and then that'd be that because the
return on investment isn't a [ __ ]
a consistent one after that so I mean he
was just talking about how he how they
plan to move things forward in terms of
how people consume different types of
genres of games and and basically how
Xbox and Microsoft in general is going
to kind of create a very developer
friendly environment to allow that to
happen so now I just want to cut you
real quick little awesome because I want
to I want to jump because the point of
contention right now where the community
right now I'm looking in these gamers
streets and the point of contention
right now is they're saying okay but the
way he's wording it is almost appealing
to the fact that Xbox is saying that not
only is it not profitable that they may
be as far from a single developing
single play experiences but they may be
going away from that based on the
successes of things like that and that
they're using the Netflix thing but
pretty much the fear that I'm seeing is
people like is this the death of
single-player games and I want to get
the Lords like to jump in on that route
oh did you backs off yes
yeah okay my jumpin my jumping on that
is uh you see how hitman has been
distributed to us and I give that as a
perfect example because if you drop
hitman out in stages let's say episodes
right this episodic what say that right
and you get a chance to play the first
episode of hitman you do your target out
in Paris or whatever and if you really
like the game you really think the game
is fantastic then you play the next
episodes I see where Phil is talking
about using that kind of model to
further single-player games and
extending the life of it because to be
honest with you hitman can keep going it
can keep dropping targets and dropping
places on hitman if you keep playing mmm
and I think that's a great way to look
for is
no longer closed off because before when
you got Zelda and you did everything
because I did everything in Zelda it's
closed off so now I'm waiting for the
DLC for the Zelda for it to keep going
and what he wants is he wants the
single-player game to have a longest
shelf life in same way as a multiplayer
game as we can throw and call it Duty
multiplayer and play it till the next
one comes out and that's what usually
happens and it usually goes past when
the next one comes out if you know
people are still playing black ops
absolutely
although or Counter Strike to take to
even further and more I got people still
playing a game released that back in
like Counter Strike but that's the
longevity he wants to see a single
player game achieve and I believe with
this model that can be achieved I want
to get a lot addict on this because I
know it he's been going back and forth
with a lot of people of this I would I
want to get you feeling these comments
and I think you know first off I want to
say anyone that are completely you know
what I saw on Twitter is people acting
like the sky is falling
yes no single player games confirmed for
Xbox and like if you read if if you've
read the auto give me two seconds I'm
going to bring up this this article that
this man did and I want to read you guys
a sentence after the sit-ins that people
are really snatching on - they keep
snatched onto that uh - you know where
he said that you know with the whole
horizon thing where he was like you know
horizon and I think he said Delhi which
is held as well yeah are rising in Zelda
he said that these titles they're just
not they're not where they were you know
they're not they don't they don't have
the impact that they did with let's say
ten years ago well clearly because we
live in a more multiple world but that's
completely off the subject again keep
doing that so I want to I'm glad to
bring it up now giggles whoo
here is the article that people are
referring to do going crazy right now
mm-hmm yeah I mean all right you guys is
down the road a little bit you guys talk
while I find it yeah I mean pretty much
I'm a jungle quick context right now is
like listen I think it was a small
comment that filled me and it is
definitely getting a lot of traction I
on it let's just keep it 100 as far as
from a purely financial standpoint right
we know that from a multiplayer game for
the most part tends to have more legs
right as it continues it tends to have
more legs as it's a constantly online
community people continue to play games
so I think what they're seeing the trend
is that the single-player game even
these low Mac these masterpieces are not
doing the numbers they did in the past
all right so I want everyone to look up
here here is the sit-ins that you know
he was talking about that everyone keeps
bringing up this whole paragraph here
now
tell me how long of a read it is from
that paragraph to this sentence I want
to make sure both narrative driven story
player games in service-based games have
the opportunity to succeed I think
that's critical for us lightly why would
he completely say he's gonna bed at
single player and the drop of sentence
like this not even as a paragraph life
like in the part that kills me is like
people were straight up reaching I could
go out of my way and say that people
were clickbait videos like like crazy on
YouTube I could go that far but you know
who you are then you know like it's just
that the part that really just bothers
me is this it's no word whatsoever did
Phil Spector say he was gonna quit do
single player game right he's just
stated that in the times we live in the
industry is more of a multiplayer driven
place he did it it's a site that he were
he there making more of a multiplayer
game uh you know compromise but not in
any way did he say you know it because
we believe the industry is going
far we've decided to only make
multiplayer games you ever said anything
like exactly that's where the panic is
yeah that's what the panic is I mean let
me jump in real quick too because this
is where I think Phil's honesty and
transparency gets him in trouble and
it's not I think it comes from a good
place because he's trying to be
community if he's trying to let the
community know hey this is what's going
on you know this is thing that we're
seeing but when people see like every
word I'm not gonna say my boy Phil ain't
got no media training it's like every
word that he speaks people hold on to
him they're trying to get something out
of it
so when they saw that sentence it was
like oh like Christmas yeah they like
you know no more single player this is
wax boxes doing you know and I get it
like it is something to be said that
your trends are showing that but he if
you really look at what he's saying he's
also trying to keep single player alive
by offering these experiences even
essence telltale he reference a lot of
other you know story driven franchises
and stuff like that how inside was like
a favorite game last year stuff like so
make no mistake like this man loves
single player experiences these are
trying to get it into a situation where
I way I've visualized it he's trying to
get into a situation where it's actually
profitable so if it becomes ongoing on
like the Netflix style service like game
pass and being able to be released
episodically then if that is what saves
you no single player makes it profitable
and then the other thing that people not
even realizing - is that like how the
Netflix model is you know Netflix has
original programming right that you can
only get there so if the single play
like exclusive everybody wants exclusive
exclusive that's the big thing Xbox has
no exclusive if this is what people want
right and this is a way to facilitate
that I don't see what the problem is
right I look at it as someone trying to
keep it alive sorry like I do want to
say one thing yeah that kind of really
really agitated did when okay okay I'm
gonna try not to come these people on
YouTube and Twitter are acting like
Microsoft has been I make single-player
games only from
from day one Xbox has always been a
multiple a multiplayer console a multi
fighters platform that sprinkles in
single-player experiences it's never
been the other way around yeah because
the whole the whole foundation of
Microsoft has been on Xbox Live and
playing with community I mean most
people who bought a 360 in the last
stuff I mean you brought Xbox because of
the sense of community you jump on a
party chat with your friends you talk
with your friends you play with your
friends continue mother and what's okay
let's look at the past three years all
right
first year we had rise second year I
think was sunset over John where was it
and that might have been third no since
it was second year wasn't okay third
year was a quantum break and record
I mean people reacted like they don't be
popping out single-player experience is
an extra part that blows my mind one
year everyone drops they [ __ ] no they're
single players abandoned and I'm like yo
single player this year was supposed to
be scalebound but he got cancelled right
right and I think I think that it's more
of a thing with it the scalebound
cancellation hurts more a lot of people
exactly that but loss on our country to
get back in I know you had some stuff
you want to say with this whole thing I
mean I think again I think it's just the
noise of the internet that's a big
exaggeration for anybody to come out and
say that it is absolutely ridiculous I
think I think we I think everything that
Phil is saying right now is by design if
you look at the recent interviews he's
had and the introduced he's had probably
since the beginning of the year every
single one of his interviews becomes
more and more focused this is by design
because what he's doing is he's focusing
the message more and more indicating
that by e3 there's gonna be some sort of
announcement in regards to this because
every he's less and less coy and in
every interview that he has and he tries
to be more and more specific about what
they're doing so my assumption is that
there is some is going to be some sort
of announcement in terms of kind of some
kind of fundamentals are the beginnings
of some sort of fundamental shift into
how they how they they provide these
games as a service whether it be on the
on the purchasing side for us or whether
it be on the development side in terms
of
developers there's something coming and
he wants to kind of gradually work his
way up to the the actual reveal of it so
that's I mean if he's going to be if you
can be penalized for trying to be as
honest as possible that's just
ridiculous and again what what scares me
a little bit is that this this whole
zeitgeist that tries to sort of muffle
the message because it isn't precisely
wet this is what happened with the
original release of the Xbox one like I
said before like they obviously they did
a lot of things wrong in terms of that
messaging but the good stuff within what
they were trying to do got completely
drowned out by the bad stuff yes yes yes
very that's a very let me ask you guys a
question would you consider state of
decay that that narrative do you guys
expect what do you guys consider a co-op
experience more uh you know that's not
multiplayer pvp but focus it's like PvE
focus I'm a huge PVE pvp odessa's and
he's been way too long
but huh would you guys consider it a
co-op PvE focus you know on the same
lines is what they want to wasn't you
yeah
to example is more friendship plan yeah
of course the original wasn't that the
original was definitely more kind of a
single-player type thing but with this
new one coming out that's absolutely
what they're trying to hit yeah and
that's the part that kills me is you
know people take they're gonna get to
the point where this man I mean you
could tell that you know Phil Spencer
has it has slowed down on his tweets on
Twitter he'd net he doesn't tweet or
talk to people nearly as much as he used
to and that every time he goes on any
kind of interview [ __ ] like this happens
you gonna get to the point where he
ain't gonna comment on anything because
I'm gonna cuddle my mom I don't think is
that I think is the fact that Microsoft
is demonize no matter what you
understand listen you go did I do you
have other companies that would say
really outlandish things and they don't
get half the furor that Microsoft
receives when they say mark microbial
things like he's trust me the service
that they're coming out with that puts
other companies in jeopardy well mom
right in jeopardy but if it's done
properly and Microsoft has been pushing
in this area for a minute and they're
trying to break that that their fourth
wall or fourth dimension on that wallet
they're trying to make sure that there's
a consistent stream of revenue coming
through that funds your fundamental of
fill foot for games so when you jump on
your Netflix and you want to watch a
movie because you know we watched the
movie last night and then I said well
let me check on Netflix to see if they
had to start another movie out it was
there so I said okay let's watch that
one too
so it kept me glued to the television
watching Netflix
well Microsoft once is your
entertainment time and dollars to go to
them right so I want to I want to I want
to cut you one second thing because I
this is the sentence that I think what
is really scaring people right and I
totally agree with you like I like the
Lord's are on it the in defense of the
noise or the internet right if what if
noise it don't matter right well yeah
but we got we gotta play devil's
advocate why are people free now and I
think the sentence as I'm rereading
right is he said Spencer fields from a
creative standpoint we need new types of
narrative experience he says but from a
business standpoint it's getting harder
and risky and caminar yeah so that's the
statement that people are like when that
is said like oh Microsoft doesn't want
to do it but if you follow through he
said is there an answer
spell Spencer thinks there is answer and
you know house type services like it is
good look at what they're doing that you
know how you know how you really compete
with that game service right you go up
to the people who make life is strange
you go to the people tell tell you write
them a check and you say your games are
coming to our service exclusively and
that that would be the way like every
month you get a new telltale episode and
it just consists of I don't think that's
that's the way to go is saying you know
your games come here exclusively I think
I don't move it away from it up in a bag
I don't I don't think dropping a bag on
somebody's porch is gonna leave you
the problems fine let it come out on
Xbox service let it come out on whoever
else's service made a better service win
I mean I have Netflix and I have Hulu I
watch Hulu a little bit i watch netflix
a little bit
they have both have different content
some have the same content and you may
want to watch a movie on Netflix because
they have the 4k streaming opposed to
watching it on Hulu real not that's
alright mostly in the chat right now he
made a real good point and he said yeah
look Phil just being real like got like
nobody really bought and supported
record nobody I bought in supported
quantum break these are single play
experiences that Microsoft invested in
and the fans are not doing this so it's
like I get what's with Lois Lee saying
because it's like he's just being real
as far as the sales he's telling you
like that is what is so we we may have
to go was you came like here's the thing
like X PlayStation was built off a
single-player foundation it was back in
the day when there was no internet Xbox
one the original Xbox of course it was
you know it had a little bit of that
when you got around to you like the halo
halo 2 era but you know it was it was
route the end of that generation and the
360 literally established the internet
when it came to gaming it did it did all
these brands it's like you know the
first modular all the entrants were
built off of multiplayer experience it's
not the same thing people like all the
fans aren't going to support you damn
straight the fans are contort because
Xbox is built off of multiplayer
experience and Phil knows this writing
and as fax guys listen yes I think what
people need to realize is that Sony has
been as successful as they have been
with their single-player properties
because as we said before a they they
invest time and money in them and they
let them slip up a little bit even if
they're not perfect their first a second
iteration the if if people if there's a
following to them they had they have
enough belief in them to continue
putting money into them that's one two
but let's also remember Eve the only
studio that is
not one or two one or two social games
away from being shut down is Naughty Dog
oh let's be very clear that if any of
these other studios release
mediocre to bad games you're in deep
trouble
driveclub shut down I mean there's
plenty of games that got shut down from
one game and that's a game and that's a
game that you can present as a service
it's a driving game you can continue you
can continue adding courses you can open
up the multiplayer you continue adding
cars it's something that you could have
continued it wasn't like there was a
single-player narrative based game but
let's be very clear like not too many
studios have that sort of leeway
I began so they have to make sure that
those every time and again and we're
looking at it from one perspective of a
first quarter for Sony that was amazing
everything changed rocked was gold
everything they dropped was amazing that
doesn't always happen and and again
these studios have to keep up that kated
if they release a bad game they release
mediocre games wanted to game down the
line they've done they've done it's just
a reality of it so it's not that
microspace is not Microsoft is doing
this is not Microsoft's thinking it's
it's the reality of the market and he's
just offering he's saying the truth
while offering alternative I mean he's
gonna do it if you saying it it's in the
works already he's not saying it just
looks already done and then any in
studio it is up for this I mean if you
look at fable lie in a studio they made
you know prefer garthe's how I feel
about fable 3 and fable 2 they made
three solid fable games that sold like
four million Plus each and then they
made a game that didn't if you get
finished they got closed down any studio
is up to get shut down and no I mean
that's true too I mean again Los Lee's
in the chat live right yeah but uh yeah
I mean it's one of those things where
like law sovereign said if he just said
that and walked away from the statement
then I would have had a problem but he's
offering a solution and he's being real
but at the same time offering a solution
and I can't get mad at that what I'm
saying so if that's the way of that's
the future of gaming too
single player alive and because like I
said it's like what loss I've said these
people it's very rare to knock out the
park these majestic single play
experiences and expect them to sell you
know I'm saying like a Zelda or horizon
like it's just we've had this amazing
good run of quality single player you
know saying that kind of bit so I don't
like people to talk about I don't look
back now that every single player game
has to have a multiplayer component
attached to it but you know what the
boardroom says we need to keep this game
generating revenue and statistics has
shown that multiplayer games does do
this
so here's where you will get something
like uh what is it um a single a
single-player game of fog for horizon
zero dawn let's let me get that right
I'm pretty sure that at some point in
time a multiplayer component will be
attached to that gang hmm well Jenna
thought that I have you've been making
good points and gigs like the trends
have been like they look at that and it
would always people complain like why
they tacking on multiplayer on a tomb
raider or not kind of but the statistics
do show that they let the longevity of
the said game Biggs extended a little
bit I'm not saying that's the way to go
but I'm just saying like regardless to
what people say Shantou a rule in the
track damage that phil is just being
real about what's going on with trends
like I don't know well accepted
demonizing them it's it's it's like I
said you know Sony their fan base was
built off the single play experience so
it would make sense that they would
cater to that market but you know as as
you know Lord sleet said earlier in the
chat Xbox fans to support single-player
games on for Xbox and you know you I
believe that it'd be true and you
touched on can you see people on Twitter
like blaming the Xbox fan base you can't
blame the fan base for not picking up a
game that they just don't anxious
they're not interested in like make the
games that your fan base is interested
or just shut up
no but they did I've been to sleep
pointlessly but they did make games you
know they maybe I'm not something I can
say that quantum break was pure trash
yeah for some for some I go way way way
to him I really like that game I thought
the game was very thought out every time
people come over and see the game and
think that I'm watching a TV show to be
honest with you and I thought the game
was great was the delivery system of the
game
good no and the reason why is because it
was set as episodic it was set as a TV
show it was set in a way that you were
supposed to get it and consume it over a
period of time which got shortened and
condensed because of the whole crap
about Xboxes doing TV and they're not
interested like Lord sovereign says they
had great things inside their messaging
that got overshadowed by two or three
negative things but perceived negative
things because we're doing that always
online stuff now they're doing DRM
check-ins now if you don't think that
this stuff is DRM checked in when you
put your game in trust me if you put a
bootleg in your xbox right now trust me
there might be secreted so don't don't
don't act like these things aren't
coming to you but what people want is
the lie the problem is Phil is not lying
yeah he's been associated Oh worries
know about this III that's what worries
me about it worries me that the same
thing that happened in 2013 is going to
happen again
that it was ever whatever negativity hat
whatever small negative everything that
I see so far
they're gonna have a lot of positive
things to say at e3 right maybe the one
negative might be the price for some
people or the Scorpio right so my worry
is that they take that messaging and
turn it on its ear and then it like
they're trying to do with this trying to
take one little comment and turn into
something else completely that it's not
so my worry is that at a forum like III
where the whole world is watch
if Sony isn't ready to take that ride
with them and to say you know what we're
doing something along those same lines
and they just want to appease their fan
base they're gonna completely take that
messaging try to turn it on its ear and
say no we're keeping gaming just the way
it is
it doesn't need me as far as the way
this is I'm here overlooking a message
yeah that thing Sony's gonna do exactly
exactly what you said oh we gotta keep
video games the same hey you put that
service up what day do you see Sony is
great a lesson I like Sony all right I
don't want it to come across as you know
you know these these people think it is
I'm standing on a Microsoft platform and
I'm waving a flag this is my console
choice yes it is
right um and that's my blood is green
but I also have a mind that has Sony in
it so the Sony is always gonna have a
place in my heart yes fundamentally are
there one single player system yes and I
understand that Lo and um addict that
that was get on the Microsoft fans want
the best multiplayer games here and
sales dictate we have stepped away from
our DNA that's what it is
Sony stayed true to their DNA and the
fans gravitated to it we stepped away
from our DNA and this is what happens
now Philips bringing us back to our DNA
but what he's saying as well because you
remember he said multi-platform games
will be best played here ok so you feel
you that's good yeah feel safe here also
few guys that fit a single player this
is what we're trying to do with you guys
you know don't know think we don't leave
you we try to build and cultivate this
as well so if the guys being honest and
I can see it I saw it and I looked at it
I said I'm not falling into that trap
because I understand when Phil is done
with it but the people that don't want
Microsoft to succeed and then some
people that just really can't stand big
corporate
and they feel like Microsoft and Sony us
they act like Sony's the little guy
he's a confirmation - you know he's a
big corporation and he's winning right
now so they don't have the same amount
of hate because Microsoft has looked at
this giant machine and they feel like
they gotta hate on it I'm Lois lives in
the building real quick I see you jumped
in Leslie here no doubt sir yeah I gotta
get your take on this
the Phil Spencer comments he tweets
right there everybody disguise Allah
what is Lord Lord a KERS in the building
- yeah I gotta get this pop you got the
full house in here
Louis that's a great works done it's
that time it's just that time to fill
the quota for bitching so it is like
like I said in Jeff Phil just be real
people people don't like that people
want to be coddled then told by some
[ __ ] what are you doing you're only
two because in their thing but it's
annoying it was the one time I data your
everyone to death and people didn't like
it but you know I do want to say
something real quick like look I see you
guys in the chat okay I just don't like
corner break I'm sorry like I don't like
okay maybe I was a little harsh to call
it trash which you know I've said okay
Laura cogito how about flip-flops from
distance they won on quantum break for
big one I'd be the casino quantum right
here you [ __ ]
I just don't like the 45 minute
interactions it completely separates me
from the gameplay that's my only issue
with but I knew and we'll get back into
the conversation can late is it it is in
the comments after my throat no no look
a good a good Oh in the building
alright so I haven't heard what anyone
else has said so far regarding it but
pretty sure someone has something
similar to me this is a classic case of
people reading but not reading yes thank
you please in a standout I can
understand some people who can't
actually read I understand there is
there is a problem with the literacy
on YouTube whatever anchorman says the
iron Lords podcaster design affiliate
with his statement okay actually with a
curb a no-bake be an acrobat was in
there was in the party I know exactly
where you go talk about it I could talk
about alone Inc let's go that's the
thing though it's just if you read what
he said in the actual article this whole
point was hey single-player games it is
much harder for a single-player game
make money that is lay fatty true back
they do not stick around as long as a
perfect example if you go right now and
you go look and see what people are
playing on xbox this is what Phil
Spencer has access to now to a much
greater than tale than we have but yes
pretty good indicator here if you take a
look at what's on there
the top 20 there is only one one single
player gating
let's follow which is almost three years
old and not to cut you learning because
me and you you know I'm the one that
brought a lot for the most part as far
as checking the most play games let's
right and when we just have a little for
a lot of little battles and stuff like
that I always said linka I always felt
it was very impressive that fallout was
up there as long as it is because I knew
how multiplayer games to trend for them
to continue as a most play game playing
with your friends it's common sense you
don't mean
so what fall I was able to do I always
felt was remark when I always gave him
credit for that
you're gonna mean but let you say look
at how funny gets people spending money
exactly hundred people you got in there
maybe one person's dumb enough to use a
micro transaction with hundreds of
thousands of people in there that's
money mmm
you gotta keep who keep on playing and
that is money in exactly true what he
was saying that all games if you have a
single-player only game that's the one
and done maybe two and done if you're
lucky and you're done you sell it back
game stop you get your money back or you
get some money back and someone else is
gonna spend it that's money that they're
not making anymore
that's a use game answer every every
single player focused development
single-player games are deadly ended up
again you playing won't everybody
pretty example this but that's not the
arguably the kings of the single-player
single-player they have tried to make it
so you keep their game like fallout
board there's tons of different ways you
can play that game there's lots of
different you have multiple playthrough
options DLC comes in and that you argue
that's a service as well but even then
you got another situation of like okay
horizons they're done you play one and
done you're good to go no alternate
ending good to go
and off or you have there's different
ways it can end and another example is
dishonored dishonored to is a great
example they've tried to diversify
gameplay so yeah I'm on my third
playthrough of dishonor if you if you
want to hit every single ending you play
this Corvo you play as Emily at least
two playthroughs and then there's high
and low chaos for both which is gonna be
different so that's for play from and
that game didn't sell well I didn't do
that good point
and like again it's a tough thing if
you're if you're thrown a single player
game and unless it sells gangbusters it
ain't gonna might not be around to make
a sequel exactly just what lost out in
the spin only reason people are flipping
out about his comments right now is
because horizon zero dawn and Legend of
Zelda just came out exactly if he had
said this four months ago know what
about it hi it's in classic I powers of
the moment I have in common and it's not
evil
alright I have a common real quick we
can go over the answer net in that
columnist section okay he says quantum
break and rise are probably the best
game sis chin exclusives on Xbox Lord
Lord Kaiser said I know he says babe
another one do you guys think those do
the best Xbox exclusives they've made no
no no no not at all no oh my god is that
name one so I take the Lord's new name
one for the man but what is the world
for rise
I think that's Google war for as yes we
can
those two of us we're gonna be real I
take recourse better game yeah well I
like yeah like real or does what work
Iser you're gonna have to state what Geo
why is because I believe
there's only one game of the year for
2017 and I can confirm it it's Zelda no
if you like Pro God why are we back at
this door that door cause that door you
open that door December I will talk
about that in this is oh yeah okay we
we're not gonna do that Game of the Year
stuff with our stuff imma shut it down
now
the doors cold it's now over as I have
painted the Year contender and it is
sneak pass oh my gosh no panic game of
you confirm I think y'all got a big feel
that it's a lot of pressure moment
reaction going on in these streets and
Louis your closely letting go to [ __ ]
for clarity but I want to move on and
now that we have blown anchor in the
building I'm actually gonna switch order
hearing probably right back because I'll
we want to talk about the Xbox fan fest
after man I know what set it off with
you and you know we as we know there was
a lot going in to this Wednesday about
you know what happened with the fan fest
situation and there was another 400
tickets dropped and some stuff happened
this week so working I'm gonna give it
to you yes let's take it away for the
people uh-oh my fellow gamers um this is
a statement and I'm going to shed light
on what happened now a lot of people
don't want to talk about exactly what
happened Microsoft wasn't prepared for
fan fests the site opening the
third-party site I wasn't able to handle
as much traffic that came through here's
an indication on how you handle it when
83 went on sale the tickets for e3 went
on sale I believe it was in January or
February and we purchased the tickets
the tickets for
a windowsill in that morning I say five
seconds and it was ready up to a
thousand mm-hmm
I was already pushed out I had to pay
250 dollars for my ticket opposed to the
hundred and twenty five one hundred
dollars whatever it was the cheap
tickets for the same thing um so if that
was any indication of the the fan base
for e3 that should've gave Microsoft
four heads up okay so the idea was we're
gonna drop a hundred four times in the
dates 400 tickets we was going to keep a
hundred tickets for promotional use only
great the site went up in the morning at
nine o'clock
la time and was six o'clock la time nine
o'clock our time and he's five seconds
in everybody got in all friends with
yeah area we got a ticket yeah you can
confirm fantastic so we had the whole so
effect you're only doing the cycles you
know some people and comes to find out
the site wasn't equipped to handle as
much traffic as it did people got
tickets they shouldn't have got tickets
was sold it were too high in abundance
that wasn't supposed to be sold or given
away all right so Microsoft's quick fix
to this was void everyone all right so
they void everybody okay yeah Africa
listen after a realizing messed up and
they're looking at it like oh my god we
really wet the bed on this guy's alright
so they did it they voided everybody out
and they said okay we're gonna do this
again next week at this time and instead
of dropping it out in increments of 100
we're gonna drop it out all in one shot
good luck guys now unbeknownst to
everybody else unbeknownst everybody
else they knew for a fact that that
third party site couldn't handle the
traffic coming because the people that
didn't know that fan fest was going on
they knew now yes so if they
add at least 6,000 people jump on at one
time the first time they had 30,000
people jump on this time it's not a
million who knows who knows the actual
number of the people that jumped in for
it okay so behind closed doors this is
what I feel Microsoft did Microsoft said
we're gonna like we're gonna link up the
site the site is going to go live and
nobody's gonna get in everybody's going
to get a weird-ass error we're going to
put a couple of plants and people on
Twitter to say that we got in we got
some alright because the ratio between
the people that said they got confirmed
tickets and the actual tickets that's
supposed to be sold well supposed to be
given out it's supposed to be 400
tickets right 400 people do not tweet
out yo I'm in not even more than 30
people tweeted out yo I'm in alright so
they have a predetermined list of the
people that got screwed
they said yo we're going to give you all
the three-month pass that went out and
people were so pissed off at that point
Microsoft said okay listen we're going
to put it up because they expected us to
put the site up no one's gonna actually
get through you're going to have a lot
of people pissed off but what we're
going to tell everybody is those people
that got jerked off the last time
they're going to get a III ticket so
they're going to be quiet all right we
got to eat three ticket and you got
three months free of Xbox Live and what
we'll do is we'll shift through the sand
and go through our fans and start
handing out tickets so they can actually
start tweeting out to people that I'm in
The Fan Fest all right that's that
predetermined list now how many of you
guys got that same error code when
you're logged in because I'm pretty sure
everybody in this room logged in yes I
got the code are you going yeah yeah all
right so I mean you know I'm going at
you in a second I'm offended that I
didn't have to do this to you on on
Twitter or in live I'm glad you hear
this is what I'm glad you're here
because the sole reason I'm here
all right this is it you're my comrade
from last year and I'm going to show you
how you changed now here we go now
Microsoft had to do this fix because
they wet the bed and ADA site wasn't um
equipped to handle the traffic that they
thought they was going to receive all
right everybody's going to get in there
you're going to probably have really a
real 300 fan base inside the conference
that's going to the show do Microsoft
deserve all the hate that's coming at
them I say no was it poorly executed and
poorly planned I say yes that lies on
one person's head if that person is the
sole proprietor that's supposed to make
sure that the function goes off without
a hitch
that's money Rumble well you got kids
listen else out here these I'm just a
finger just point now I'm just saying
and and no but I'm saying that he meant
well he underestimated his celebrity
he's Twitter she Peters and these people
understand that they following Chris all
the way through so of course the you
know you know stuff rolls downhill and
it hits to hit the person on top first
sorry Chris you at the top it hits you
first and then it rolls down on
everybody else everybody got messed up
in this whole show but kudos to
Microsoft for fixing it as much as they
possibly could because you have to think
about it that if 1,000 people got those
tickets I got those confirmations
they're handing out a thousand III T
three right you know and then ya good no
no I just wanted to jump in on that too
because it's like look you know we
understand the situation like no one's
sitting here not understanding and to me
like we said you know last I LP my whole
thing is what are y'all going to do to
make this right
it's not from an entitlement standpoint
but you know shout out the low rule in
the chat like people receive emails
congratulating them
they are going to fan sex right right
now granted am I the person that the
minute I get an email like that I'm
making a slight no but there are a lot
of people who from want to say yeah that
I've secured intensive purposes the
minute they got that they were starting
a book and they like look I got a jump
on these hotels I got a jump on these
flights I got to see what's going on so
when that happened my feeling is okay
Microsoft you have to do something that
you like now when we heard three months
of Xbox Live no that was the answer I
was looking that personally rubbed me I
felt away about that I'm at least a week
old on me
let me call Safari little statement and
we got an answer that we've been told no
I didn't get to him yet I didn't I did
not get to him yet
right now this is why I'm closing it up
come Microsoft did a great job
all right from from this guy who doesn't
have a fan fest ticket or didn't win a
fan fest ticket from Microsoft the
Microsoft did a great job they gave me
III and they say y'all listen that you
know his a III ticket hit three months
of life I'm pretty sure I don't know if
you booked the flight or not or whatever
you know the case maybe you know but
here you go Lee's gonna trip it's not in
vain
you understand you're good with we're
gonna clean it up as best as possible
other companies wouldn't if they would
avoid it that thing did it over in
whoever's que sera sera sera all right
now what I'm seeing here is I was
looking at a lot of corporate butt
kissing inside Twitter and I thought I
got a verifies this you come in after
anchorman oh listen you gotta set up the
anticipation of it you gotta leave
crumbs for people to pick it up and they
can see and they're gonna understand
who's he going at because everybody in
the chat or on live is like who is clean
talking about my comrade and on my
comrade-in-arms now at the time when I
met this man he was Rage Against the
Machine corporate people ah
I can't stand them so I didn't
understand why when Microsoft bungled as
much as they did he was on the side of
the people of your whiny little and
Microsoft owes you nothing
hmm okay now to that my friend I say
Microsoft owes me everything the reason
why they owe me everything is because
I'm that guy that made that line the
first time that they was they were
dropping I'm that guy made sure that I
buy multiple systems I'm a guy that has
actually all those games that they
dropped those first party games that
everybody wasn't supporting I can't say
not me I can say I did thank you totally
sometime when okay that's that's a great
thing but what happened in that Twitter
room where I thought I was looking over
the comrade-in-arms I did not know that
they gave you a side patch because like
you said and I'm glad that you outed
yourself so well when you said that you
don't need a fan fest because you were
in already mm-hmm
so dammit to the little man who doesn't
have your press pass that allows you to
walk in and you look back at me and said
fend for yourself brother I'll get you
some kid you see they come your way
if you did see anchorman walking in the
door and they just and look back and
like thank you
yeah they asked you how many in your
party and you said a party of one we
gotta let Eddie get aside the very least
initially he's waiting on he's he's
getting ready his gun is ready
trust that shield I got oh I got more
bullets to come
oh man same bullets is nuclear bombs
honestly felt that being as influential
as you are and how heavy your voice
carries in a ring with as much followers
as you have you would have took that
time and used your celebrity to help the
little man mm-hmm
was more disappointed in the fact that I
looked over at my brother I broke bread
with and he switched sides okay
he became Hall Britt Captain America is
a Hydra agent we were hot brew I was
always never stay busy I'm devastated
and I would really like at this point
time for you to come to accountability
on your actions in this place but you
know you know what you know what I only
got one thing I could say hail Hydra
with my hydra crest on Oh Mike you see
there you go good thoughts ah it's true
it's true that the room is in the street
that you have been turned your
Decepticon yes
now keep in mind in the past FanFest
is it was your ticket into e3 it was the
only way to get into e3 because all the
tickets were sold out it wasn't over to
the public per se it was this is the
only way to get in this year's different
III is public there are tickets still
available you could pay that money
instead you want to leech on Microsoft
to get in oh yeah oh you got a letter
you know talk been accused tumbling Oh
III tickets have you paid for it I did
that broke mine already I brought it
today it came up $250 you want me to
give you the confirmation number the
email how many years have you done that
I've done it only once the year that it
was available on a fan fest I went last
year sir
I just heard outside 24 hours I was
outside I was making sure I made the
light did you make the line last year
sir uh who gave his ticket away sure mr.
room to kill got in here hey why am I
wrong sir
sir this is the one-on-one fights up
looking to the left
now he's great I am I look at it as this
III is public this year it's available
to RT and yeah Microsoft screwed up but
I look at the situation as oh you if we
took out those Microsoft and we did it
okay if we look at it as I gave you the
situation about a week ago I said hey if
you are if you're looking to go to a
concert and you're not in basically they
do a contest to get into the concert for
free and skybox treatment all that good
stuff and they say you win the raffle
and then they come out - couple hours
later oh sorry about that that wasn't
correct I'm sorry can you be out there
demanding things from them just
demanding like oh like the what pissed
me off was people coming I gotta say
people be mad I I totally agree with
that being pissed off about the
situation I've been sitting at you won
yeah I mean people yeah i'ma giving you
a couple of pissed-off yeah it's when
people demand something in return of I
was slightly inconvenienced I was like
white like not white I all right I could
find out like I think this is they they
never said hey go book your tickets
you're getting in they never said go do
this now they people immediately waiting
to do that kind of stuff that I I just I
can't understand that you're but I gotta
give you I got a higher I get my my
scenario what happened to me okay you
don't leave it without them
that the issue I have is when people
were coming out and like this how we're
giving as three months of Xbox Live
sorry about the inconvenience this is
free to get in this is Microsoft giving
some for free you're not entitled to
anything
mmm and then making a right that is on
them to make the situation right it was
when people will say hey we're giving
you guys three months Xbox Live we're
doing a rear a full sorry about that
we'll get it back to normal like you
you're lucky you got anything that's a
bit wait to do things but I don't worry
about you I'm gonna give it to Inc I
just wanna get one right one point that
I think we keep
missing and the point is when the sign
up for the Xbox fans was made right
they said that you need to release your
credit card information the purpose of
it that if you do not show up you are
going to be charged a hundred and fifty
dollars or whatever that amount was so
there was set value on sign up if you
don't if you don't attend so that that
thing where I just want to make sure
that that's not lost is that even though
that yes it is a service that they are
offering right and it is free right
there they don't have to do this for us
I totally get your point but they did
tell you if you didn't show we're taking
this from your account and a lot of
people like Lord addict you know Sam and
myself putting their credit card
information to a third-party site that
is egregious that didn't work we also
have to assume that we have to trust
microsoft with our sensitive and we
don't have to trust microsoft we have to
trust the person they decided again -
yeah I mean that that's a big deal
I think that's credit it's not trusting
Microsoft now ready we have to trust to
do that the screwed up to make the
website to not crash back I was not
aware of that particular aspect of it
little dinky bone I mind though no I
understand no I mean of course you will
not be aware of that particular aspect
we are peons in your world because look
down upon us with your corporate badge
my brother can I can I ask a question
here just angry acity the whole issue
here is people were set said they want
tickets for today to get them right yeah
they got me to say anything I got all my
stuff I got I got my confirmation they
said sorry that's not correct we're
raffling but they did that the hours
after they did it three hours after
continuously far the regular III tickets
available to buy huh
yes you've always been available about
Oh
and like acre a creator a partner to be
being just a simple man why are people
bitching because oh yes come you ask
them you go for it and I'm amazed that
three is just for the three day the
convention fan fest I mean III does not
include those tickets do not include
access to the Microsoft press conference
that is what everybody waits can't shoot
issues so just apply to go to the
conference no no okay I have to be
meeting all you could is your media or
YouTube channel
maybe but yeah I got info cannot apply
to your Microsoft press conference I
bear me out differently random people
going in and sitting in the nosebleeds
present wisdom mostly where you guys are
sitting last year you guys are sitting
on on the front floor front stage right
there in front of Phil yes then in the
second rain like right there like they
are the premium box seats that's what
the press were and then in the top
nosebleeds that's where all a common
folk work who actually remember
correctly anchorman you was in the
nosebleed section though I wasn't hot
you know what he nodded to talk with the
right section of them no he was no
you're standing from Phil position I was
in the back left-hand corner what on the
on this ring I could walk down into it
okay that wasn't common people that was
the other 250 people Microsoft let in to
the conference that stood outside for 24
hours but again you were not with us in
the pit you would not understand this
because again we are peons and you
looked at them like you said
as common folk let let's leave it as yet
avoid over there yes is this Lord sleep
continue here's what they look like I
said as a simple man let let's say but
let's take this out of context of like
III video games and you're not right
let's say this is I don't know it
forever some fancy Auto Show or
something right and and it's like couple
people we're going to win this new model
of car now you were going to get raffled
for it and then they botched the raffle
you
so instead the same amount of people or
more are gonna have the chance to win
that car but everybody is gonna get
something else let's say a cart for free
gas right if you don't get that car but
you get that gas card
why you wanted you went into this
knowing that there's a chance a very
good one mind you yeah um a more of a
chance that you won't win then you will
our water phone is we went into this
with a chance of us not winning we went
into this with the chance of maybe the
website's gonna crash and no one's gonna
get in we did not go into this chance of
everyone getting accepted and then
taking five hours to tell anyone
anything happened Lord Lord Lord really
her though we did get reimbursed a value
because it was according to Microsoft
$150 an hour credit card information
yeah so never understand you got nobody
that's whatever say you get what you
deserve
no that's the point right I mean if
they're gonna charge us $150 for not
showing on this ticket that we were
supposed to win right and then now you
messed the they mess up and say okay we
you know it was a botch thing we're
gonna give you three months of Xbox Live
that is not of equal value that's all
I'm saying
that's one thing but they're talking
about you're going up on the date yeah
right then but they had an attorney to
persuade you family acid fee there right
they want to make sure that you're not
just getting it because in the purpose
of the credit cards that they that we
also don't sell the ticket to someone
else that was the other what you do to
buy a ticket
I lost lot sleep I I want you to
understand right um let's say you got up
that morning that you did let's say you
got up that morning
you waited or you took the day off of
work I know a couple of people at 6:00
they'll work Microsoft didn't tell you
to do this market you this is what you
do on your own okay you do this you take
the time out you respect the process you
know crying about the process the
process is changed midstream because
last year you
while to LA in hopes to get to eat three
tickets Lisa give you ahead of time so
you're not out there that night find out
it doesn't go right for you all right
some people that went that way now you
have a heads up on this you go and you
get it you get your ticket you said you
you did what you did these steps you
follow these steps they rules this kind
of weird you said I'll give you my
credit card 150 if I don't show okay I
don't know if anybody dies and I can't
make it out there at that Perry at the
time plus I got to get charged $150 but
I'm in Microsoft whatever you say buddy
you get in you got confirmation what's
the first thing you're going to do the
first thing that you're going to do
knowing that flights and hotels and
everything goes up by the second it gets
closer to the date that you have to
leave what are you going to do when you
got your confirmation
you got ticket in hand you ready what
are you gonna do okay you embrace your
stuff but at the same height okay all
right no you booked is like the way even
a real hot but even as a person who
wasn't even trying to get in I could
tell just by watching Twitter - that
[ __ ] was sketchy it wasn't real old age
because they said how many people were
going to be in a couple hundred and
everybody on Twitter got it oh yeah yeah
see by the one you knew at that minute
that they were the first twenty minutes
and it was something wrong from the very
beginning that would be sister you wanna
say that you know anything for sure but
you could tell it was blue that's all
said okay but is that it's almost like
there's no sympathy for someone who
thought they won and booked the ticket
and fly I'm not saying that but you
think the focus I'm just drunk I'm
trying to clarify I'm not so I'm just
the vibe you're giving is that what I'm
saying hell is people got something it's
not what they should have gotten but
they did get something if I say
Microsoft did the best he could have to
agree that guess
the equal value right we were cool I'm
good but you know what Microsoft did do
though after they heard that that three
months was an illegal route value it
equated to $25 right okay so what
Microsoft did was they said you know
what the base value of the e3 ticket is
a hundred and fifty bucks okay give them
the base value of that take you give
them that ticket and we're going to go
$25 above that so what Microsoft did in
fixing the problem is they went above
and beyond yes and this is what I say
for them and whoever stepped in and
fixed the crap show that was going on
thank you because you fixed it but I was
dis concerned and disheartened by my
fellow my comrades that had the platform
and the air of the industry of said
people that they talked to him rubbed
shoulders with and have a higher what is
that uh views podcast where they could
have stand out and so then justice that
was committed upon the common folk say
you can say it yes so but my man stepped
up he came in the room and hail Hydra
he's in a building piece at least be
saying that yes I'm a corporate sellout
and don't look for me to help you he
said it hail Hydra he said I might help
don't look for me to help you I'm down
with this team I love you guys I'm here
and I respect that I respect the fact
came in it was like you pansy babies
exactly I respect that you stood all
your tools on that platform and he
respected I can honestly just say that I
respect that out of respect I listen at
the end of the day all I was saying what
we said we're not going to reiterate the
whole song in this but it was just
amazing to me what Microsoft did this
Wednesday and I felt you know what this
is what I'm talking about this is how
you make it right you know and I
Phil Phil had maybe something to do with
it because you know the last day I
didn't expect e3 tickets like that's the
last thing I love exactly babies maybe
e3 tickets for the following year but
not this year by eating right and to me
it's like I feel that Phil knows the
importance of this e3 and to have any
negative energy coming into the
conference you know I mean would not be
a good game
and to be honest like to offer that was
amazing so the ball story is Microsoft
lady Belle and above right you know a
lot of people were going to e3 now to me
that was amazing but that's what I had
to say anything I thought this was a
funny past two weeks watching everyone
good but you noticed this also to all
the lords in the room my narrative
changed as the week progressed because
in the beginning of the week had we did
this podcast when I set all the tweets
out you know keep your eyes out for the
podcast on Sunday how'd you did the
podcast is going white really good right
now
totally different and during the week
Microsoft fixed their footing righted
the ship and did what was fair that's
all I said I mean listen my flights my
hotel and my stuff was booked a long
time ago I was going to offend I was
gonna stand out a fan fest that was my
mindset
I even had my little blank a my little
charge kit I had my stuff I'm getting
red onesie my chair
my chair is still out in LA my momma
comfy seat is still out there ready to
make this line because my blood is green
like I said I waved that flag so I was
going when lose a drawer I was out there
and I really appreciate the fact that
they fixed it for everyone and not just
for concern so from there the beautiful
look beautiful oh so we're not gonna
beat this too much in it in the head but
we want to move on we got that's a lot
of stuff to go on and I want to jump in
right now basically I want to bring to
the table as far as um obviously some
big releases got announced right we got
Call of Duty's World War two but you
have to battle for it to release dates
and it's looking like November 3rd and
17 respectively for both of those titles
so what I wanted to bring to the Lord
because I want to shout out actually on
ijen a lot about McCaffrey I made some
points and I thought I went unnoticed
and I went to bring it make some good
points
now with those release dates right and
we do know typically Microsoft systems
tend to drop in November that has
historically been their kind of deal
that with Scorpio approaching do we feel
that Microsoft can afford to launch the
Scorpio at that juncture considering
that most of the multi plans will
already be out like again let's just say
let's use the 15th as the as a day cuz
generally Microsoft tends to jump around
my birthday right historically so um
let's just say so by that time November
3rd call duty will be now you know prior
to that destiny would have been out on
prior to that what shadow of war you
know all these triple-a titles when my
resplendent cell right and everything
what the exact all these exclude now you
that the strength of the Scorpio would
be that multi-planar going to run better
do the Lord's feel that Microsoft can
afford to launch that late and also when
if not when do you think they they will
launch a Scorpio so
all right buddy first thing I want to
say is I'm gonna go down the line what
day do you think it's coming out
anchorman the Scorpio whatwhat time for
go down to the day timeframe like
monitoring oh hey Doc showed it uh Lord
sleep uh mental enough ever Kingdom
August data I mean oh you know I'm going
down with the ship with you baby
no I'm going down - [ __ ] - okay yeah
Laura sovereign the sovereign early
November all right and I'm late on
saying uh you know end of August early
successor so you know okay I think this
I think the best time for this to come
out I think it should come out to say
that shadow war comes out and then the
next month they capitalize on destiny -
they can't market these games but you
know they can you know obviously will
cost the money the best way to combat
the marketing that they don't have is
when destiny comes out was like what
September 8th
I believe yeah so September 8th comes
around couple days before destiny -
comes out on Twitter mayor Major Nelson
says Oh in any if you buy any scorpio
bundle you get a free game on September
8th only tell me that would not work
it's sad just just to make a cover real
quick I mean these avatar day all at
least they've gone Dolezal at least all
the podcasts that y'all they stated the
whole universe were few launched an
August thing yes yeah y'all my egg
shells this is gonna be another one
that's it that you waited I'm Sparks was
that first ad the marketing deal with
destiny
and I told y'all from the beginning that
was never gonna happen
honestly y'all know and you may be less
don't waste no reason why I would tell
you that it will come out in August is
because the S released in August and
finish [ __ ] one last party right here
because of it I mean because of that I
understand that people are like oh
they're normally in November launch
title it's like a narrative Phil Spencer
was not in control when the original
xbox came out Phil Spencer was not in
control - 360 he's got a lot more
momentum and he clearly Xbox clearly so
what kind of advantage they had -
dropping out a system in August because
they want every month up till November I
mean I look what question another
question I want a question for Lord
Sovereign Lord Lord our sleep
specifically for the November for them
seven correct all right so what's your
guys feeling but let's just say it stays
true to form what you guys are saying
right and it comes out November what are
your guys say to the people who say okay
why would I buy a Scorpio cuz let's be
honest with those
games already releasing right destiny
you know all these things on calling all
that stuff right most people are going
to buy PlayStation 4 or the standard
Xbox one version right my question is do
you know you don't think that it will
hold any weight to wait you know I mean
something like you don't think that
that's - Microsoft's disadvantage to
wait that long I as far as doctrine on
the street I think my feelings of this
when when you look at launching an early
no I think they look at the long game
and my thinking is that anybody who's
going to purchase a Scorpio in when it
launches is going to be a person who a
probably has an Xbox one or Xbox one s
already mom I don't see I don't see a
lot of people who are big PlayStation 4
owners they only play playstation to
jump to Scorpio so the person you're
trying to sell the Scorpio to at launch
is a very specific type of person who
probably owns both platforms that are
already or at least at least at least a
Microsoft platform so my thinking is if
that's the case well if you buy if you
buy the game on xbox one you've already
bought it on Scorpio mm-hmm so you have
the game there already so it's just
prospect of you can start playing it
when the game comes out and then you
switch over to Scorpio when it when the
Scorpio is released and you're playing a
better version so you're not worried
having to buy a second copy of that game
played on Scorpio so that's one thing um
and then secondly I just think they need
as much time as humanly possible to make
sure they get every aspect of that
system correct when it even down to like
the UI make sure everything is running
well with the operating system they
don't want any any foolishness in terms
of works Oh exactly exactly so again
Phyllis Phyllis stated multiple times
that you know they're ahead of schedule
what that means you know we don't know
what that means
um you know so honestly what what I love
it to come out in August yes Hey
love that and yes in terms of
positioning the fact that if you do have
that person who hasn't bought either
system it is just waiting and and heard
about the Scorpion said you know what
I'm gonna wait and buy a Scorpio I don't
think there's a lot of people like that
but I think if you do have that person
that yeah launching it as early as
possible makes the most sense but again
I want the system to be ready okay no
fair enough fair enough we definitely
don't want any mistakes and mostly your
your whole mentality wouldn't November
like wait where you at with it as far as
yeah I wanna say I'm having this same
mindset as Asahi reviewed its
Harbor dashboards and stuff are still
having issues for preview programs and
I'm testing you know functionality is
what I don't want that new system takes
a night shut up - are they ready to go
must breathe yesterday with that preview
program it's not only that but I'd
rather here's my thing I it's I know if
released in August I could get it and
then I could get a chatter war right and
then when those games come out and
they're there you go pick them up and
all that stuff but I I mean personally I
would just rather go into a story get my
system and have more of a choice at hand
at the time then shadow or not also the
Scorpio is going to enhance all your
existing games that you probably have oh
my god but I've played those before
stuffy a disconsolate thanks what's up
but you guys were there with me
when they said holiday 2017 isn't August
oh it was none all Fool's Day Hollywood
in 2017 and oh but he's came out
multiple times since then like Laurie
said and said they are way ahead of
schedule so yeah but sleeps like a good
point they need to have
well that was office up that thing he's
not gonna come on and say we're behind
schedule
he's not gonna sing
Wow he doesn't have to restore her head
or hello or anything they are on
schedule but he came out particularly it
said that they're ahead of schedule I
also got around with people
why are we so people saying when people
say holiday especially in these kind of
visits this that extends into the
beginning of the next year as well this
year my thing is we don't one with mats
they they wouldn't put up shadow of
mordor and tell you all the
functionalities that the Scorpion does
get this gang this game is so great on
Scorpio really when do I get a chance to
play that game well it launches in
August and the scorpio comes out too
much later damn no yeah that's what I'm
so what would you the game have all that
compatibility though and they not
mission it until deliver well you know
my game is gonna come out date date name
me one other time name me one other side
that's something like that's ever
happened like they none they're not
gonna okay that was the first time
they've ever even acknowledged the
Scorpio like out while on Twitter and
not only not only did he did he say he
said it was coming out for the Scorpio
like why would you three months four
months before that game even came out
say it's coming out for the Scorpio when
you know damn well you're the games I
could be out when it comes out it's like
it may have no sense - that's like a PR
nightmare like no anger for this yet he
has some stuff with the jump in and we
cut the thing in particular though I
mean they called it Scorpio I mean you
might want to like I would I would read
into a little bit of the astrological
sign meet even the devs of it a dog you
want them people you know the
astrological sign falls October 23rd to
November 22nd yes right and I think it's
in their best interest to drop it in
October as opposed to November November
might be a little too Lakers you want it
you kind of want to hit that Black
Friday market as well in order I want to
drop in late late November where it hits
Thanksgiving and they already gonna put
it on sale
like now you wanna drop it so it's out a
couple weeks and then it then it goes
out on sale and by Friday like I I would
put it there
now it also you're kind of in the middle
of things
yeah although all the early games
already came out but we got Call of Duty
like this is Battlefront coming out
after that and the games coming out
which is gonna have Scorpio support but
you also have a few games beforehand or
to get it you have people get other
games coming now I think there's a very
interesting component to this that will
be mentioned and it was also kind of
hinted at yesterday by Pete Hines um
there are there is a bethesda game in
the works in the show of a game coming
out in October from Bethesda having an
Xbox marketing deal and that games
selling it and I know room and I were
talking about oral sex I don't think
it's also Elder Scrolls 6 yet but if
it's a game that shows off the power of
Scorpio it becomes that game not from a
third party perspective so cuz like
everyone said all first party stuff
clearly it's going to be worth like
built for Scorpio where they show a
third party game running that now
imagine probably opens nice just say
this okay let's say that you know
something else that happens that the
Microsoft is different but let's say we
go into the Pathet and they do somehow
now it's Elder Scrolls six which you
know me and anchorman talk we don't
think that's gonna we don't think that's
the case think it's a little bit too
early maybe next year would be a better
time to show that once if they once if
that's got the marking dough and it's
demonstrated on a Scorpio at the
Bethesda conference right do you think
that would have relevance or like more
specifically magicus Microsoft's going
first
they had Nate these haters Scorpio yada
yada and they show they got teased
something and say we come back in a few
hours they're the better shows an
opposite on Scorpio here and yeah
absolutely
I guess I can say that yeah okay I guess
the reason why I'm I know Louis loved
sleaze laughs he's like you guys go down
with the ship and we maybe uh you know
and I'm not I'll be the first to admit I
can go on I can eat this [ __ ] listen
I'll be the first to admit I can be
wrong
here's the thing is my mindset and as
well a reason why I was thinking that
it's just that kind of looking is saying
it's that okay we do know that it's the
first time they even mentioned school
you know was in conjunction with shadow
of war which is an August release then
the way I looked at it was okay and this
is the Lord attics point you know last
year just last year you know the slim
was released in August at his hip in
unprecedent we released a what was it
really and and for all honesty was kind
of a staggered release right cuz it was
like almost like limited quantity in a
little bit and then as it went on it
hasn't run and my long Terrell I saw
that when I saw that last year is like
what a perfect way to get momentum
because if we look at last year's
history right Microsoft continued to win
NPD from that point forward remember
August 2 what does it send that but they
don't everything lost because the
ProCare not right and which was in our
system so my mentality would just like
look yes they could launch in November
but don't you want to get Scorpio in
those hands don't you want to show the
reason why you buy this platform because
we all know Sony has the marketing deals
right they got the battlefront they got
the call of duty the perfect counter to
it is yeah you got the exclusive content
but our our game looks better using I'm
saying like if whether we have more
functionality we got 4k we're doing X Y
& Z and I just thought it would be the
perfect storm so yeah I'm going down
short you know if you think about it the
biggest thing that this does that no
one's really talking about is if it is
in August they got like three months to
get everything in order any kind of
launch issues they're having fixed
before they add start pushing these out
right I'm just concerned if they follow
suit and they launched November
how much yes and sovereigns right with
the long game sovereignty you do
completely I feel your point on the long
game they may not even be thinking how
can we thinking and it made me think
longer but at the same time how about
momentum these executives don't look
like they think in long game they
talking about every game coming out this
year
that's warrior the the reason why I'm
saying August is because everybody would
sit inside the conference and I want you
to really think about the people that
was at the conference the fillers change
in the culture right and it starts from
moving these dates and moving these
regularly scheduled programs stuff that
you were used to so when he was showing
the s we saw her we were sitting there
like wow yes
it's slim is small yeah you fixed it it
is the brick is inside and we were all
going with it and in our heads
subliminally we were saying ourselves
November I can't wait yeah and when he
dropped it at the end and you'll begin
to be able to get this pin a couple of
weeks in August yeah he said what what I
was blown away that was the moment yeah
I was like that I didn't know what a
shout-out what rule in the chat made a
good point
they're making 4k games in like two days
it's these versions that they're doing
it this thing it's so fast and it's so
easy to to translate and I want to also
shout out Lord a little anchor like I
think Phil is with that philosophy what
is it what is it gonna get where it's
under promise you got it you got and I'm
starting to think about I know this
ain't part of the subject that we talk
to the topic right now but I'm you know
started talking about the price now may
party and I get with that with a career
nobody Lord ekam I'm seeing the light on
certain things certain things of like
the way Phil talks to me this is how I
perceive a lot of his stuff is that he's
gonna be honest but at the same time
he's gonna make you go wow I didn't
think that was gonna happen like the you
know the over promise thing like that
whole mantra I'm starting to see it so I
don't know maybe I'm looking too much
into it but we know let me say my
mentality here alright thank you good
good Leslie toes they crushed my dreams
it's over it's over again
hey expect a premium price expect a
premium and 89 and like downplaying the
power a little bit downplay it so then
with the power come
sounds like oh wow it's actually decent
oh [ __ ] it's really good and it now it's
Alan to be the price that's a bombshell
and if you look at these meet these
meetings in uh these these interviews
that people are having with Phil on Xbox
on he said he said he was talking to
people at rare and he said you know
we're seeing their undeveloped game you
know saw he's we share some stuff from
our ended welcome to he's like but when
I walked in there he said the first
thing I said is just don't ask me the
price in the day in the name that's all
you can ask me if they ain't telling
they own first party studios thought
that it's clearly something they want to
keep to the chest did you hear about
that span would the price be doing
anything anything yeah yes it's funny
thing you mentioned that because there
was something that was kind of crossing
my mind also it just seems like it's one
of those things where yeah definitely
like over under-promise and over-deliver
and to me when you think about any
console at its launch is a premium
console any colossal whatever vision
bitter $2.99 console at that moment at
that very moment it's the premium price
for that console so you know yeah
exactly and Phil could definitely play
with words like that so yeah and that
would be something that he comes out on
stage and says 400 and drops whoo yeah
hopefully if you do that that's very
points though people people thinking
premium prices you're not thinking
long-term how funny I would be if you
looked it was a console manufacturer
you're making what you paying $400 every
seven years maybe six seven years if you
cut that in half and you basically say
hey we're making $800 every seven years
like it ultimately the consumer who goes
for that kind of thing is going to be
paying more in the long run that's the
premium price be on the cutting edge
what it's not a lot like up front like
usually a lot hmm
mostly I would love you baby this is
subjective
yeah this out anyways exactly takes it
takes it on a different connotation when
you're talking
about the cadence of releasing systems
that they're talking about now like
we're gonna see mid-cycle refresh is I
think from here on out so yeah premium
does take on a different meaning you
talk yes sir replacing a console every
three and a half four years ago
no cause be interested it's gonna be
interesting man I mean we got to see but
I thought I thought it was interested in
that are we starting to get more of a
timeframe as far as when these games
coming out and I was just looking at the
big picture you got all these major
games so there's gonna be interesting
see where they decide to release this
thing and if they go early and try to
get momentum or if they you know play
long game go save you know Glenn
November whatever hold on last day
Leslie we point out that that's it
really good anarchist right that there's
no denying that right but but where I
set out what that whole thing is esta
good but it was just like a little
difference between the system you know
it just did things better right the
Scorpio is this big monster thing you
want to watch that at primetime not
somewhere that worked so you're gonna
don't you don't subscribe to the whole
idea of trying to get momentum out in
August when really there's I mean on
September where there's no system that
are usually bought let's take for
example the switches launch right the
switch launched in a traditionally non
system launch month no we're on to
system they're not look at like how
they're doing and then the other thing
other counterpoint I want to say to you
is sometimes we also accused marketers
often these companies of bunching up the
games right like November 4 or 5 premium
titles and then you know we like them
you know this game could have been
launched in you know like say titanfall
is the number one example right you know
damn well titanfall should not have been
released when it was released last year
right you had battle fight extension
battlefront and on battlefield and uh
what you call Call of Duty now if they
would have just launched it a couple of
months away to let it have its own
little chime you know I mean that's my
mentality object of the thing of
launching the Scorpio in an August or
September so you slowly build the
momentum you get that month to month
kind of a bit and it's like now come
November
really kill it cuz now you can throw
fondles you can don't deal I don't know
to me you see more versatility we do
people like me would not buy it in
August cuz look at ASCO if it comes out
in August right what are y'all walking
out with beside shadow war that's enough
for me
I am four or five but you're acting like
a noob in this isn't this is a fresh gen
that works on old games will Army in
November what are you gonna get like
it's the same thing regardless what time
I gave but he don't wait don't sell a
game law you don't sell us backwards
cathodic ok ok I want to say something
real quick Tim all right so let's say
they don't you know they want to do they
can't do a shadow war because they want
to do it November what else game do they
have marketing with it they can that
they can put this out what they have for
selling gosh every Xbox list that
they're not gonna try to sell this
before is to do guess they are they
every xbox live within the hood exciting
this is the party for Salman I don't I
bet they're not gonna try to rely solely
on for that itself Scorpios yes it'll be
something else too it would be something
run we haven't talked about about they
see the games are coming so there's got
to be something in the pipeline we don't
know about well none of those things
red could be quickly I don't I don't I
don't see crackdown to till November
actually I don't see that to them but it
could be
besides fourth or something else yes
that's another thing I don't think I
don't arrest it loyalist arrest that
would be all those multi plastic coming
around that part of the year that
everybody thought about Lord sleep I
would like to say this right when you go
in a store you can't really play dirty
games I mean I've purchased a system and
got all 13 launch games or whatever that
is and out of all those 13 launch games
I can only play one at a time right I'm
a speaker so I'll work from home alright
okay so you can play twenty discs at one
time I don't never saw something like a
do this Oh
but he's like you think you know Amy no
I don't know don't commit to one thing
all day all the time but I play
different games all at one time that's
why I have so much downloaded at once
yeah I'm exhausted
I will not meet the test but what I'm
trying to say is all right what would
you rather do when you go inside this
store Lord sleep would you rather go
inside the store purchase a system and
you have games that's ready to rock that
you already you know gonna play you know
the the whatever you got those games or
would you rather go inside the store pay
a thousand dollars come home with 15
games and get busy how do you want to
spend your money Lord surely I'd rather
get my system I have a bunch of new
games to play so you want to steal a
thousand dollars every time hell yeah
it's gaming is an expensive hobby that I
signed up for this okay right so you in
November so this is what's not stopping
Microsoft stopping you right we're going
to release in August and when you're
ready to come spend your thousand
dollars in November it will be on the
store shelves and you can pick up all
the games you like because the AI has to
wait to see what my silly guys sleep
acting like Microsoft at a gun day every
gamer say you picking it up with August
you wait because all that pick it up in
August wait behind sir I've confirmed
one thing they are doing a tiered system
which is help definitely gonna help that
that B that's how they did in the August
the highest tiered was sold and then
later on the lowest tier is came out
that's how they did last year
write me up see what happens was the way
I mean it could go a lot of ways the
girls gravity over so far bigger deal
and is not happening I don't work is
that s is a huge deal brother the fact
that it had 4k blu-ray in the Box had
HDR functionality out of the box the
fact that the power brick is removed and
it was shrunken down that was Phil's box
it is true that's Phil's boxy teeth he
took the monstrosity of the regular Xbox
and Russell let's does a staff with slim
it stands for Spencer yes sir insider X
mr. X media the S stands for Scorpio in
an e3 he's gonna turn on the switch
there's an extra SD card let me let me
say this stuff okay and I'ma press the
button Michael Corbitt this is okay
let's say Microsoft does launch it but I
would not put it past them okay like
anchorman Lord anchorman said you know
the tears you know they got that to tear
about $4.99 in August and then they got
the 399 in in October November
I mean that way if you want to be an
early adopter you got to put down that
money and they did that with the s and
they sold like hotcakes all the way up
to its so so what the $400 what how much
was the gears long because that was the
first one one that's what I got
just 100 all I'm gonna say to close on
my thoughts on this right cuz when the
console launches in November like usual
I want you you specifically Lord at it
then Lord because if Carly doesn't know
I will be late - we know here you're
finding I'll be wanna know I will tell
you this
Lord sleep fair to date when it releases
in August I'm just gonna look over at
you Lord Cognito Lord addict about the
destiny marketing deals and gone on you
get it twisted now oh let's not get
ridiculous let's not be reduce you gonna
look at it chat you're gonna see this in
the chat what
good with that you'll be let let's
justlet's man yeah we're right there on
the podcast go man Phil likes playing
destiny Brophy because he sells
everything well this is like that in
this latest video yeah yeah one in a
matter is he was making that comparison
to show you the papillary that it's that
one of the number one multiplayer games
and his favorite game and the hours he
put on so let's that try to minimize
it's like did my way away on a Harley
that's the let's play more multiplayer
on a multiplayer set your key destiny
that's the point you're not listening to
okay I just think I understand you might
give us our major no but I'm just a
little bit let's not act like there's no
connection that we were just clearing
your sky and praying for something to
happen
yeah you're the play overwatch give me
the year 2016 all right let's move on
let's go really yeah we'll see what
happens
ah all right so we're gonna move on Lord
addict I know you got something as far
as I'm sure anchorman gonna love this we
got we got we got the controversial
topic all right so you know there's a
lot of speculation that comes the games
you know some people think you know you
got your fours or your halo your gears
you know call a duty to certain stand
battle feel kind of because you know
they what I want to talk about today is
gangs that you think that's been over
Mildred you think is so trash that they
should just stop them oh my god
everybody knows what's on my mind so
we're gonna go ahead and go down so
anchorman you go to you go next Lord
sleet you go first
Oh fine I guess I'll tell our visions in
division diversion then let my lord I
don't know what replacement
ladies now Nene you yes it is
we all know that I'm the resident
division fan in here and you happen this
date okay Kara start you hold it I
didn't tell you to subscribe to that
though I don't tell you to subscribe to
November release date November date
August is Jo main brother and that
August day is gonna break your back it's
your Bane and I'm a sit-down I'm a look
at you and I'm gonna put the sentence up
and understand told you school and when
it's not happening I'm just gonna put it
I'm just gonna weed out a simple ha you
know what the funny thing is you know
okay so it's clearly but let's just corn
is real quick before we move on case
after I say is we'll move on but okay so
lord King David you know he got that
August Sophie he ain't right on August
and it comes out in September October
he's clearly wrong you know it's
whatever but you gotta have November so
that comes out any of the must between
that you lose you still finish right you
still think we come on Lily does don't
be so here's the thing I'm not making
this isn't a bet I'm not pulling a Lord
at it well the whole Nestle just thing
we finish up through your timeline when
it's s it's gonna be holiday like a
traditional job out of the guy that's
why I know we bleed a tangible bet here
something like some clear de fire we're
moving on now that pulling on that phone
adding more well more gel television
kill it the game you really sit here
thinking that's all you can think uh
yeah they give me give me a minute I
have to get past my division hey get
over yourself well this last time
anybody else besides King plated I don't
play for you to play it this is big like
oh yeah
listen millions of people play the game
I don't see it on this place and I say
this to you right this is what I say
when I say to you I don't get I want to
say hey sleep let's go take care of this
raid in this no no no I'm playing and I
got my friends that play actually some
guys a viewing the podcast right now and
listening to the podcast and they're
putting a thumbs up and they're saying
that's right King my monkeys loving it
goes out to you baby we did it
well I guess God y'all can have fun get
in a group of three running around hey I
just want a question for like why do you
want fresh eyes to be killed I'm just
kidding
I mean it was next to destiny which
didn't let me rearrange this quick you
gotta have three good reasons why you
think this game should be dead now
here's the thing like maybe I don't
actually want it to die I just like you
people know you got you always hiding I
got a dollar pass thank thank you we
appreciate your money let's move on
here's the thing though I always get
before hard time why do you want your
money to die I don't understand it
do you all purposely and go buy animals
open for their death you are sick
brother I'm coming okay my stuff you
wanted to say I said division we get
that kind of rise out of you you got go
right now gorgeously he clearly said
he's a preposterous claim so working
what is your mattress the game that I
want a canceled and kicked to the side
well it doesn't have to be canceled it
could be any game put out coming out a
franchise that you think's just being
milk too much that needs a real is the
question oh well a lot of games I see
all these these yearly reiterations of
games I would say Call of Duty hmm and
only reason why I would say Call of Duty
is this reason right the new Call of
Duty was coming
a battlefield said last time okay we're
gonna take it back to the essence we'll
go back to one let's do it baby and they
took it back to World War one Call of
Duty sorted sails on battle films like
damn we messed up with this space crap
um yeah let's take it back to World War
two they did world war one let's do
World War two and I said damn man mister
me two is in the building again I'm so
sick and tired of them being mr. Jutras
Yeah right
they used to be at the forefront and now
they're playing catch-up and what I
think is maybe they should take a step
back walk away for a little bit uh
pursue some other IPs but the boardroom
doesn't allow that to happen
and they gotta turn them out I don't
purchase every year so that's my caveat
I get it for free so I can't really
complain but if there's any franchise
that I say that deserves to take a break
and step away for a little bit
it's them I would have said madam before
but it's them like I'll give it honest
answer thing is with this question I
really there's really nothing I could
save because it would be Call of Duty
but it seems like they're hopefully
getting their stuff together right and
then I would say Assassin's Creed as
well but they took time off the fixin's
yeah yes I mean there's just not much I
can really say I'm gonna be honest
could be a diss again that you think
doesn't like doesn't need a sequel wait
it could be anything like that I don't
mind I don't mind the loser what asked
of us two people felt it had the
pressure I just played last of us hmm
and it's no doubt it's a good story it's
a damn good story even however it's just
okay as a game it is just okay hmm it's
a basic basic gameplay it's really
hampered by the PlayStation it really
shouldn't get this the what kills me
about it that notices IV on placing I
just got a PlayStation if I've had it
for about about a month or two now and
what stinks about it is the d-pad just
from a shooter perspective that's a side
topic altogether it's just it's okay
gameplay and the story was so complete
we're out Joel and Ellie were the best
part of that game on a story level and
the way it ended was great it was Master
Craft not need to be changed yes and
going any farther is a misstep because
all you're gonna do is just piss people
off go change and then doing that should
have happened if anything it should be
somebody else
but the problem is the world is garbage
and standard like a post-apocalyptic
sinister SIF all I can take a car mouth
oh my god let me say some good news I
gotta get off in a second but I just
want to throw this out here real quick
it I don't want things games to die in
particular but I my overall feeling on
this it's the same of like the movie
industry and everything not everything
needs a sequel yes I grew that doesn't
need I had one of the best with people
huh white writer does not need to see
yeah I think last of us it worked like -
Ayton serviceable gameplay but a damn
good story in there they're bringing
back the only thing that was good about
it which was the characters which is
nobody really can do I get mad about it
but it's they were done they were
complete the story was told there's no
need for them to exist any longer
mm-hm no I feel after your point I mean
I want to jump in home it's gonna be
controversial with understand oh no like
- yes
oh I don't outside of this year and I
understand why this year because of the
Scorpio but I'm tired of fossa play I
feel for these a break and I love was
horizon
don't get me wrong that hot will enjoy
that they just dropped I'm feelin it
gonna mean it looks lit it's just that
the I'm worried about this like they're
doing the call to do anything with
horizon or you know and the motorsport
horizon like horizon what do they go
make oh I get it
it is the seller it is is doing its
numbers it's it's killing it's just I
just I'm just exhausted from it okay now
I know we gotta get for the Motorsports
11 I know it's gonna look spectacular
let's go up y'all with without question
I probably might might pick it up I'm
not good luck but it's just one of those
things with just like it's so synonymous
with Microsoft and I just want that
whole mentality to change and that's one
of the franchise's I think needs a break
it just needs a break you got to take a
step back a little bit let it be missed
create other things in the interim now I
did hear playground was making arm their
own type of immoral game I believe and
that got me excited because I like
pleasure
those are the bees I'm gonna do the
horizon series but I don't know how
y'all feel about about I wouldn't be mad
if lesser women away from it I get it
it's not even about the good quality of
the games the games are great games
great no it's a consumer fatigue we're
tired of heaven completely fatigued oh I
just want it like sounds like that's a
great example they took a your honor and
now automatically buying Assassin's
Creed Empire automatically I don't even
need to see gameplay
don't you mean to see it I want to play
how much fun was that speed game nore
sovereign you do yeah yeah yeah we're
nice treats which one needs to go away
or what your phone is good milk what one
needs to get eliminated is dynasty
Warriors completely ago oh my god you
know what's funny
the Android sleep spot in the party
that's funny - yeah you have not
improved that for god knows how long
that's the
like the Zelda dynasty warriors alright
10 frames per se but massive magic thing
I almost follow say that the other day
either way for free I have it I was like
nobody actually download this give us a
chance like nah I'm good though that
topic
I'm sorry Okazaki finish use get them
yeah and the show the show needs to go
away for like new you watch a version
that's been controversial because
there's no one to go somewhere else
before it goes away a little bit you're
a baseball guy your resident base will
get hitless I'm surprised you said that
to a man too many I mean again this year
it's the iterating and it's an it's good
improvement but it's like it just still
looks the same and well I don't don't
you think that's more of a kind of like
when man who fell into the whole thing
when they were the exclusive being on
the block
remember when 2k used to battle them
don't you things more of a like a lack
of competition to push them so they can
kind of just sit on your laurels kind of
thing yeah that's what it's what it
feels like it's like they're sitting on
their laurels and it's like okay and
then not because obviously they have
nine months to turn a game well mm-hm
but it's just like it really is this
nothing that they're improving upon in
terms of the look of the game like if
you go year to year there's nothing that
you're looking at saying wow this is
really different so to me just two years
to kind of come back and just give it a
fresh coat of ink completely so mad
that's it oh look suffer mad in the
disease mm-hmm I think you guys are
gonna really be surprised well that's a
big oh that's me okay y'all I should
have taken
I think square-enix needs to hide the
glows up for final fantasy just ended
please we're gonna call it final final
oh no more final Fame you like that
final fantasy the latest one
it's just look like you know the more
they make the the more they take away
from the older ones and you know 15 was
good but the only reason so many people
like 15 is because it was a [ __ ] ton
better than 13 so like you know like I
did that Final Fantasy is one of those
titles that the stores are all original
because you know it's not a sequel per
se there's very few sequels in Final
Fantasy but it's like look you guys have
been rolling so you guys pretty much
started the JRPG brand like you guys
started turn-based games like you guys
just need to end it okay like Dragon
Quest 2 it's just like you know like
these these games so you don't want
turn-based that's what it is no it's not
even turned base that it's just like
position there they're hitting miss with
that final fantasy right now and they
they keep messing up the brain and every
solutely hold oh hold on back up one
second cuz I recall that you said that
this last Final Fantasy was a game of
the year Canadian yes and it is but the
last three when he made was trash before
okay so you talked about before this
list it with it you know it got a no and
I think one of the only reasons this
game turned out the way it is because it
was a development so long and you know I
it's just look like let your brand be
what it was known for and don't keep
trying to reintroduce it to a modern age
and ruin your brand in the overall in
mmm so even with this success you okay
with it just going away deal with this
latest big blockbuster success I'd be
like going out on a double you instead
of going out on L okay okay like and
let's say that said that the remake of
seven comes out and they butcher it so
bad like you messed up seven I'm pretty
sure you've lost about 50% of your final
fantasy fans because that is by far one
like the most loved Final Fantasies and
I know a lot of people that are like if
Square Enix doesn't need a mess of one
game it is the Final Fantasy 7 remake in
Kingdom Hearts 3 those are the two caves
that if you mess up
people go [ __ ]
you up it's real out in the streets
because even now it's telling how many
release dates what's going on with it
it's supposed to be episodic you know
seven is my heart seven is like I love
the Final Fantasy brand I'll always be a
thing but you know I think it gets to
that point and you know it's a few years
down the line that you just you need to
need to do something else you don't need
to try to keep milk on your franchise
because that's one of the only games
that you really that your bread and
butter it's like hey whoa but you know I
think hay was a little bit different
because halos not they're not nearly as
long as Final Fantasy well at least they
listened in the latest comments a halo
stating the day back they're gonna
involve Master Chief more is it that
that makes me worry about that makes me
worried about halo because our I mean
did they do that when the the game
actually started in production or do
they recently just like you know what we
because if they did that it's like are
you are you gonna go back track and do
the story and the story is going up
being like half-assed because you redid
the whole thing for Master Chief you
would have second I think so I think
they gonna put more Master Chief than
anyone after the verse of stuff oh you
think we're just one of those things the
backlash that the campaign hot and they
realize that you know what people wanted
morning they just said they recognize it
and for the next halo that they're gonna
focus a little bit more on that
they say they realize how much beloved
he was or whatever which I thought
that's ridiculous they tryna trying to
cancel them out and start something new
or fresh and then realize that you don't
go angel yeah I know they were secretly
trying to repack the brand you think is
a good I just think though I mean it
doesn't have anything to do to because
to me like the problem was a lot sucked
it wasn't it was efficient I could
Google lock just suck I don't think it
was long I don't think it was Master
Chief I think what people had an issue
with the shady shady marketing the lying
and that is the water oh yeah they may
not remember monkeys learnt at at eat
with you at in the Microsoft booth they
had that advertisement on constantly
pleat below behold the fall in
hero and they make it like it was this
big matchup you know say like try this
we're always trying to make you look at
them as adversary so much this would not
look at Cortana like even a little bit
right and they they try to make it seem
like you know he was this big traitor
and that you know it could go either way
even me Laura a good man win any like
how don't would it be if they had the
balls to actually kill G you don't seem
like they had so put some old friends
only the only person on that show that
would have the audacity to let kill
chief is arbiter that's the only person
that would even remotely have the pass
to Cochise and then the other complaint
was that day he's brought in don't Haley
all Massachusetts peaking lines so it
was a lot of disconnect with the way it
was done and at least I'm happy the day
a meeting it they're gonna you know not
go that route and focus more on chief
and the story so Lucille Adams but
anyway we went a little over today
we had a lot of stuff go away wait wait
wait wait wait oh yeah my bad wait wait
no see well everybody is fundamentally
forgetting and this is a very crucial
thing what Microsoft is doing on a
hardware level on the act of metal
alright so we already know that
Microsoft has embedded DirectX 12 into
the chipsets right so make it easier
like Lord sovereign was explaining to us
the tasks that it takes is no longer
arduous test is it's like a set of 500
steps it only takes like 12 steps to get
to a certain spot now what Microsoft has
done and they have patent is is a
Microsoft direct physics and it's
directly linked to DirectX 12 they're
trying to fade out the DirectX 11 to
make DirectX 12 there you know exclusive
go to but the physics base um software
that they're introducing at a hardware
level allows for the system to correctly
calculate fall a paper material and have
it move realistically in there
environment without taxing the system
and they showed a demo of it running and
is much like the physics on Nvidia PhysX
X in the same capacity but Microsoft is
doing it and they're gonna own that
whole proprietary engine for the Scorpio
and in this is big ditch is huge mmm
my thing was did anybody see it read
about it because you know I put it out
to you guys I do you have any thoughts
on it before we close up because I know
we went over it is huge it is no remark
they they purchase havoc they purchase
havoc in 2015 and they kind of hinted at
that point that they were gonna find a
way to integrate this sort of middleware
into their hardware moving forward and
in particular on dx12 so once once they
indicated that dx12 was was burnt was
caked it was uh was baked into the SOC
for the Scorpio I mean this is something
that this is something that I knew was
probably coming I didn't know they were
gonna sort of rename it um so it
basically is just hack havok physic's
engine kind of evolved with a new name
and what's great about it is like what
Lord King was saying once again they're
taking they're taking these things these
are these processes that are usually
very heavy computational processes and
they're baking them into the SOC and
making it more efficient and quicker to
the draw so that like the power onus is
not on the developer to try to figure
out how to use this phone it's already
just baked into the system it makes I
mean ordered what it does is just it
makes life a hundred times easier for
game developers to me old and I'll jump
in real quick twos all this is is
getting closer to the metal it's making
life so much easier for them you just
say here you hand it to them and go and
then they can use their resources and
focuses elsewhere to make it better I
mean this is to me this is the only
thing I know coming into mid generation
refreshes I was a little nervous this is
uncharted territory for us I'm not used
to it
but the advantage of it is that now you
have a company like Microsoft who is now
able to cater to specific engines that
exist that's another thing I mean
so that's never been done before
normally when a system is made they
don't know what you know there's gonna
be an unreal and is you know mean like
those things are developed and mostly
around is usually goes the opposite way
so what's happening right now is really
unprecedented and a lot of people are
not paying attention I'm glad you did
bring this up ok like this is so to the
metal this is now optimization on an you
know next level and we're gonna see some
really cool stuff
the come out of these games that a lot
of people are not expecting and I'm very
proud of Microsoft this is really cool
stuff and I think like a lot of people
are not realizing the weight of this
stuff you know especially with the dx12
and all that good stuff so I'm hype I'm
geeked your bill I'm ready I'm ready for
this coffee to come my hand in August
like I said I would like to reiterate on
that August 8th um
fair to date um I really honestly
believe that it's coming that in that
time because I know Phil is putting his
mark down and people quietly have been
saying that s doesn't stand for what
they think it stands for a sense for the
Spencer box so they innovate men shut up
the recording old shots were Linda
Chapman I've been live in there but we I
know we went over your apologize for the
UH the difficulties in the beginning
Lord addict needs to be hosting he knows
that like realize his little issues
hotels but I we get to thing uh well
before we go we're gonna get the Lord's
our outros and we got Lord anger first
of all shout out the low anchor for
coming through or some real grown man
it's not like you get attacked
we were we were low upset with him
earlier in the week but as a man I have
so much respect for you for jumping on
staying at peace and how you feel so
Lord anger where can people find you all
the good things going on in these
streets with you you find me on a
Twitter and command-v to our word saving
PlayStation
Xbox Twitter beam twitch I got that
synergy I know who I am
oh let me say this real quick sales on
Twitter right now talking about he might
wear a share for horizon zero dawn III :
she's like feedback taking maybe I
should wear horizons your dollar shirt a
t30
god but series will come out loosely the
multi first kick in and take over the I
know yeah I got them yeah moving any
streets baby I always listen to you guys
respect it so we're gonna get down
around Oh Lord addict wakin furn
furniture you find me on youtube I'll
definitely be looking for that I have a
I'm about to be doing a Recor addict
spotlight probably today or tomorrow
most likely tomorrow
oh you catch me on Twitter iron Lords
podcast kami addict of Lord Aizen iron
Lords podcast um any kind of gaming
services room to kill no doubt no doubt
and of course Wiccan lost I went to the
people now find you back some up every
week if we can not find me on xbox live
at px averin and on PSN add up examine
one word in excess gamer Lord King
oh if I'm not better and Xbox at all
King David OTW
and you can find me on PlayStation
Network and Xbox 360 lover what get a
brother podcast is coming to you soon as
that media room is done we can get these
visuals and get everything Papa no doubt
looking forward to it of course this is
oh thank you thank our man yes you egg
man I really appreciate you being our
well respected man Thank You Manny the
peak brownie ish and of course is having
a corporate corporate home like that
like I do here you have your Twitter you
know they look like Nina and I um check
me out on Xbox Live has Cognito PSN the
whole bit and switch gang but no social
security numbers will be given out until
you guys get on Mario Kart 8 and get
this work from black shy guy we're still
the best pocket guys never heard yo
increase y'all in a chat yo y'all it you
know maybe you speciate the support like
subscribe share all that good stuff and
we still got stuff cooking man
especially you got some III Alma
specials going on and some great guests
going on so creation love and on that
note we out peace